je sais ça va vous faire tout drôle mais
titanic
à 20 ans le 19 décembre 1997 le
mastodonte de james cameron débarquer
sur les écrans américains
deux décennies plus tard les effets du
triomphal naufrage titanesque se font
encore ressentir
il ya bien sûr le phénomène titanic les
chiffres faramineux et les délires des
fans on y revient dans un instant mais
il ya surtout le film lui même
en mettant sur pied ce tournage
gigantesque hors de l'ordinaire
en mêlant pour la première fois effets
digitaux et grand cinéma
cameron a prouvé que les effets si j'y
aille le cinéma digital si vous voulez
n'était pas réservé aux blockbusters
fantastique non un vrai grand fils de
cinéma pouvaient utiliser l'outil
digitale au service de la vision du
cinéaste
lors d'une interview plus récente il se
rend des comptes qu avec titanic il
était le premier à avoir combattu
l'étrange paradoxe qui s'était imposé
entre technologie et art
cinématographique et notamment qui tient
depuis pour le triomphe de titanic a
aussi prouvé que les spectateurs
n'avaient pas de problème à accepter des
images générées par ordinateur
et quand je parle de triomphe je fais
dans l'euphémisme
à sa première sortie en 97 donc le film
a remporté plus de 1 milliard 600
millions de dollars de recettes dans le
monde depuis titanic est ressorti
plusieurs fois notamment version 3d et
il en est aujourd'hui à plus de 2
milliards 187 millions de dollars et ce
uniquement en salle un seul film a fait
mieux au box office de tous les temps
avatar de james cameron titanic était
donc devenu un phénomène public à
l'époque surtout auprès des adolescentes
mais pas seulement
la petite bête en piste et à l'époque ça
aller beaucoup plus loin que simplement
retourner voir le film les fans étaient
plus que dévoué il était obsédé par
titanic à los angeles
encore plus qu'ailleurs les expositions
avec des objets recueillis sur le
titanic se multiplier les ventes aux
enchères de tout objet reliques ou même
télégramme d'époque liés au titanic
atteignait des sommets
la chanson de céline dion se vendaient
par dizaines de millions de cd les
couvertures de magazines se multiplier
les paquebots avaient la cote
quelques mois après la sortie du film en
février 98
nous étions allés faire un tour sur le
queen mary un paquebot ancré au port de
long beach et qui jouissait d'une drôle
de popularité depuis la sortie du film
on a eu énormément de coups de téléphone
pour les gens qui veulent venir se
fiancer ou venir se marier ce a attiré
beaucoup de monde dans ce domaine là
mais notre événement préféré de cette
étrange folie titanesque c'est ce
dernier dîner du titanic organisée dans
un restaurant d'hollywood tenue d'époque
objets répliqué à l'identique est
exactement le même menu que celui servi
le dernier soir sur le titanic
tout était à l'identique même le petit
sifflet pour
ford
faux
la musique services météo
ce soir là tout le monde se prenait pour
les eaux et kate juste avant l'iceberg
m
et aujourd'hui titanic reste tout
simplement un des plus grands films
jamais fait le pari fou de james cameron
le film qui a simplement tout changer
vingt ans plus tard on sait qu'en
matière de cinéma
il y a un avant et un après titanic